all right sophia
sophia where did you grow up where are
you from originally
uh
here in southern california
and tell me about your uh your family
growing up you had mom and dad
i was raised by a
i had had aunt and uncle
nearby with a lot of cousins
where were your parents
my my mother passed when i was very
young
and my father was living with his new
wife oh i see
how would you describe your childhood in
general
uh a caretaker
uh i i try to give a lot to the people
around me
so you're a caregiver yeah
yeah
but yeah but your childhood
how was how was that
no abuse no
nothing traumatic i i had a a few
experiences that it uh
required some therapy later on in life
yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh
a private one
uh i i was uh homeschooled for most of
high school
uh i graduated from a continuation
school
you graduated yeah you went on to work
uh no work
it it's it's something i had difficulty
with
how do you know i'm 40. you're 40.
and you're living on the streets now
yes how long have you even living like
that
it's it's been
uh
about seven years
are drugs a part of your life
there is some drug use
uh
mostly
um to
to
alleviate symptoms
of what i go through
how do you support yourself
how do i score myself how do you support
yourself support uh i get a check every
month um i'm registered with a
social worker who who tries to get me
housing
i'm i'm working through the process of
getting an apartment oh good where were
you staying in the meantime
uh with a friend
have you been on the streets before were
you just
sleeping on the street or in a tent or
anything yeah yeah
that's
it's got to be rough right
it is
it can be
so you're transgender that's right
how long have you been
seven years seven years okay
did you always know that you had this
orientation no my whole life i i was
very feminine
but i i didn't understand
the the concept of being transgender
and
when when i was in
my early 30s
i was talking to a transgender girl
and her opening up to me about her
process of transition
made it
clear to me it was something i wanted to
do for myself
and it was a very beautiful experience
being able to express myself uh honestly
as a female are you are you happier this
way oh yes
definitely
do you feel like you were born this way
or is this something that happened to
your childhood born this way when i was
when i was
a child i had family members correcting
me telling me things like
don't walk that way you walk like a girl
don't laugh that way you laugh like a
girl
so
[Music]
do you have friends now
yeah yeah it's
it's hard to maintain connections with
people
when living on the street what's the
hardest part of this lifestyle for you
uncertainty
it's it's hard
not having transportation when when i
need to get to a doctor's
appointment or
or when i start thinking about
possible employment
money's got to be hard to come by
without a job yeah
what emotions do you go through
do you get depressed or angry anxious
i i distract myself with uh community
uh improvement so
i i tend to do a lot of making other
people's lives better as a way of
keeping myself busy and distracted
that's nice
have you ever been alive before
yes i've been in love
how did that go how was
it
it was
one of the most beautiful experiences
i've ever had
that's wonderful
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
i would have focused more on
on working at an early age
that that was uh a major obstacle later
on
not having that job history or not
having a career you could
specialize in yeah
does your drug use get in the way of
of that
no it hasn't it hasn't been an issue for
me so far
and living on the streets as you've been
for the last seven years is how has it
changed you
well the the people have changed over
the the several years that i've been
living on the streets as well
in what way
it used to be the community was very
soft and warm
and
it's gotten
kind of scary kind of violent
people
people saying mean things to each other
do you feel like you're targeted because
you're transgender
yeah yeah
you feel misunderstood
by most people
i i think some people don't understand
what transgender is
or being transgender
i get i get asked are you a male or a
female and i'll be wearing a
full-length dress and
it's
a cognitive dissonance there
where i don't really understand their
position and they don't really
understand mine
what do you wish people
understood
so that may be
transgender
yeah treated differently it's it's an
expression of the the self
it's not it's not like
um
dressing up and pretending it's not that
it's a real
experience of self as the opposite
gender of what we were born as
you you see yourself as a female you
relate as a female absolutely even
though you still may have
male genitalia i'm assuming
right right
but that doesn't really matter it's it's
still in your eyes you're a female that
is correct yeah yeah it's gonna be hard
for people to grasp that some people
well most most of my social interactions
don't involve uh sexual contact so
it's it's usually not an issue
uh it's it seems to be more of an issue
for the people that are
against transgender people
what was it what's been the worst
experience you've had
i've had
repeated
uh abusive behavior
coming from
some individuals
and it just it doesn't make sense to me
these people went out of their way
to make me feel worse and i wasn't
affecting their life in any way
it seems terribly unfair because you're
all you're looking to do is
help others and be kind but you're being
persecuted yeah
it
it
like i say i i don't understand their
position uh being anti-transgender
it they they go out of their way to find
people to be upset at or upset about
and
it has nothing to do with their life
it's not like transgender people are
knocking down people's doors to
take over their family or things like
that
yeah i i have a hard time understanding
that behavior as well because you're not
a threat to them i assume it's all from
males right
yeah yeah it's not like you're a threat
to them you're not going to steal women
away from them
right
so they shouldn't be threatened but i
think what's really going on is they
are secretly turned on by
transgender women i've heard that that
the people who have
the most
uh anger or hatred on the surface have
underlying issues of attraction right
yeah
yeah it's
it's
it's a crazy world we live in
what was your best memory as a child
uh i have a
christmas memory that um i'm very very
fond of it's it was i was with my mother
and my father and my grandmother
and it was it was my first really big
christmas
and that's that's a big one for me
that's nice yeah
are you still in contact with the family
that
your your family raised you do you have
siblings
uh i have two brothers two sisters um
i don't see them very often i don't talk
to them i i try to make contact once in
a while and they're busy with their
lives
i've
kind of been separated from my family
for a little while so you're kind of on
your own yeah
what gives your life meaning
um
world improvement uh i'm big on on
seeing people and situations improve
like i'm i'm just geared towards that
so
[Music]
seeing a person
become better than they were is is like
a huge
daily goal of mine it's wonderful yeah
what are you afraid of
what do you worry about
uh i worry about
the the state of society i we were we
were
headed towards
what felt like acceptance towards
everyone
and then there was a a strong turn
somewhere around 2016.
where we started behaving differently
towards each other
there's a lot of hatred in the world
yeah
you any regrets in your life
i regret uh
being pushed past a breaking point um
stress wise
i i
wanted to be
a purer
uh
expression of who i am
and
i had some
some uh
problems
that create kind of cascaded into
worse behavior
and that's that's a regret that's
something i'm still trying to make
better
and sophia what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
be good it matters
really
society is based on our daily
interactions
and if we
mistreat each other it becomes
a bigger and bigger problem
wonderful sophia thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
you